hello and welcome to learning about it
with me lulu today we're going to be
learning about discovered attacks a
discovered attack is when a piece moves
and in doing so and uncovers an attack
on a different piece what plays efore
which black meets with e6 the french
defense not immediately putting pressure
on the center white then plays d for
putting both puns in the center as is
logical when you are able to and then
black plays d5 striking center like a
bolt of lightning boy plays 'if I've the
advanced variation closing the center
like then plays c5 attacking the center
white defends with c3 black attacks
again with knight c6 white defends again
with Knight f3 and then black a text the
center again with Queen B six white then
plays Bishop d3 a tricky developing move
tempting black anything you can win upon
for free so black takes the pawn on d4
white takes black takes again with night
this is a devastating blunder for black
as we will soon see so what takes with
his night black takes with his Queen and
he looks like he's going to win a pond
but white has a winning discovered
attack Bishop b5 check a discovered
attack on the black Queen winning it for
free so black plays Bishop d7 blocking
white could easily take the Queen here
but he wins more material by taking the
bishop on d7 so Bishop takes d7 check
Cain takes d7 as we can see white has
prevented black from castling here by
forcing to take the bishop finally Queen
takes d4 white wins the Queen
so to recap today we learned about
discovered attacks a discovered attack
is where by moving a piece you uncover a
different piece that is attacking
something thanks for learning about it
with me lulu